i've been thinking as as i do about this
book right here which is
a classic of the sci-fi genre one of the
greatest books ever written in my
opinion
and i want to talk about a little bit
about its author
frank herbert and a certain comment he
made about
leadership basically what i'm trying to
say anytime a person
takes power that power should be
questioned you know
simple concept however very often
missed very often overlooked especially
when leaders are charismatic
now there are some comments that frank
herbert made that aren't
considered the best of takes or some of
sometimes they are but certain people
are like okay that's bit hyperbole
that's a bit ridiculous but herbert says
that the better president
was nixon you know the recent presidents
when he was alive was nixon because
nixon taught people to not trust the
government whereas
kennedy was very different i think that
our society was formed on a distrust for
government
and we seem to have lost that distrust
of government
i kid around and i say that my favorite
president in recent years has been
richard nixon
because he taught us to distrust
government herbert was
writing paula treaties atreides as
a type of jfk a person who creates a
kind of myth
of himself there there's this idea that
this
these charismatic figures carry with
them this power this glory
even beyond the grave now i don't think
nixon and kennedy are the perfect
individuals to compare in this way i
think that a more
apt comparison in terms of presidents
would be nixon and reagan a lot of
hatred is thrown in nixon i think nixon
is a fascinating character in his own
right
fascinating person however i do think
the worst president
i don't know if this is gonna bug
anybody but i think the worst president
of the
like second half of the 20th century was
reagan
because like frank herbert said about
jfk and kennedy
reagan brought absolute charisma to the
office he
brought all of these reagan democrats
over to the republican side
reagan crafted the neoliberal economic
policies that we have today that are
dividing
wealth within this country nixon was
just he was at the cresting moment but
nixon
and it's very hard to even compare the
damage that these presidents done
obviously nixon
horrible president vietnam i mean total
total horrible yet that horror was so on
display because nixon was a [ __ ]
lunatic nerd like nixon was just a big
weirdo like let's just face it he was
very uncharismatic a person who was
obsessed with
putting on this image of positivity when
he was anything but he's very dark
individual kind of tortured brain and
this kind of
quality made it so transparent so easy
to pick on him in a sense while he was
in office and look and see the hypocrisy
because he was
bad at lying he couldn't even convince
himself of his own abilities to handle
the situation
full of insecurities et cetera et cetera
et cetera shakespearean character
shows how [ __ ] messed up and
ridiculous
the united states government is you have
hypocrisy
corruption just absolute master class in
exploring and showing to
the people the issues totally collapsing
this faith
in in the us government which i think
was a necessary thing
obviously it was not worth the damage
that was done
comparing that to a figure like reagan a
figure who's in some ways like paula
treitis while
the atrocities carried out under his
name
because of his ability to lead his
charismatic leadership
absolutely incredible reagan was able to
get away with
so much more reagan did not show this
damage he put on this facade of control
and leadership whereas
all of this turmoil was happening all
this the deregulation of the economy
this economic framework that would lead
to this
huge wealth inequality and horrible
horrible damage that reagan caused not
just
within our country to the working class
in the middle class but to
countries all over the world i guess
this is a very
long-winded discussion and a way for me
to talk about american presidents and
politics a little bit
to me this is the essence of what frank
herbert was getting at in dune this is
why in the second book of the series he
totally
undoes the myth that he sets up in book
one
it's sort of this slap in the face to
readers a necessary one and it seems
like that's what in a lot of ways
people need in order to wake up and see
what is wrong
being lulled into this false sense of
protection
by individuals who are extremely
charismatic especially individuals like
presidents
you know horrible things that occurred
under obama's presidency that were
glossed over
simply because he was an extremely
charismatic individual
say what you will about trump he is like
nixon
so clumsy and obvious in his
ridiculous foolish personality his
horrible demeanor all these things lead
to him being
while for some people extremely
charismatic hopefully it's not just
orange man bad that we're dealing with
but hopefully people are seeing the the
systems that led to trump coming into
power the systems that led to
polarization in the country this kind of
wealth disparity
when frank herbert talks about nixon and
he talks about how nixon was
in some ways the best president he
doesn't mean that in
in terms of the actual fulfilling the
role of president
he means that by saying this kind of
role is
corrupt regardless it's going to be
fraught with
problems and that when people are
naturally accepting of their leaders
they can be led to do horrible horrible
things
like in dune and dude messiah without
that constant
questioning of leadership so i really
enjoy that aspect of dune and i have yet
to finish the full series i've just read
the first two i'm going to read children
of dune soon but when i reread dune i
want to dive even further into what
frank herbert was saying about politics
how it reflected the politics of the
time in which he was writing
the books he takes us on this journey
through this long book with the
character we come to love
only for us in book two to question why
we love him why we care about him why we
go on this journey with him when we
consider the consequences
of his regime anyways that's my rant
like like this is just a rant
about nixon and dune and frank herbert
and kennedy i i love talking about
politics and history and stuff and
science fiction so hopefully there are
some out there who find this interesting
because i found frank herbert's comments
interesting so what does everyone think
about frank herbert's message
that's my take i hope it was uh
enjoyable thanks for watching like and
subscribe
to man carrying thing what does man
carry man carries
dune duh